hey guys i'm ryan right hi I'm Lorne gah
we're gonna check out this video today
called the weirdest video you'll ever
see I don't know what the [ __ ] we're
about to watch but I'm hoping this lives
up to let's hope
it's already really weird
Oh
the offices some really merry cancer
it's kind of cool that was weird
everyone has this thing where they're
walking on crutches right so this isn't
something about like trying to evoke
thoughts about people that are
handicapped okay is it like a is it like
a symbolism for like we're handicapped
by our set like we handicap ourselves in
a way like we limit ourselves it could
be everything about it looks like it's a
real struggle for what they're doing but
then some stuff doesn't make sense to me
like the opening guy has like a pipe in
his mouth the first guy you see he has
like crutches and he's got like a crutch
coming out he's got a crush coming out
of his forehead maybe he can only
breathe through his handicap and that
they're also naked we're like well half
naked
Samiha like the crutches might not even
be a crutch necessarily it could be like
an extension in some way or I feel like
maybe the person who created this or
choreographed this piece or show or
whatever this is that we're watching
maybe wasn't an accident of some sort
and overcame their injury mmm and danced
again and maybe this was a visual
interpretation of what they went through
the first guy's buddy we see is like
he's on crutches and he's like dragging
his feet so it's about like trying to
get back on your feet and also like this
is little clips it looks like little
clips of different dance numbers in the
entire show
yeah it doesn't start with an opening
and it's cutting through it doesn't feel
like one long right so it's not like
we're not seeing the whole I've seen
segments I'm trying to understand what
it's about necessary no I kind of like I
wish that there was a little description
because I almost feel like instead of
saying look this is the weirdest video
ever maybe originally this was a really
beautiful piece yeah exactly this might
be something beautiful but then I would
get confused because at times the crowd
will be laughing but maybe there may be
a meant to have intentional laughs at
that point but the dancers always look
so serious at the same time it
definitely feels open to interpretation
so I feel like some people I mean I'm
sure you guys have your own
interpretation too you'll probably tell
me about and then that girl she's
crawling and she has like a microphone
in her mouth that she's moaning I mean
to me that's like a symbolism I mean it
just looks like sex to me like it's a
symbolism for YES on the first scene
when they're guys walking past there's
two people behind them mm-hmm yeah yeah
that's right
okay let's try to figure this out so
crutches sex they're half-naked but have
naked thing like in a lot of dance
pieces people aren't very much close so
that doesn't necessarily true but
they're like down in their underwear I
may have seen dances we're like yeah
they don't have a shirt on or something
or they're wearing something kind of
revealing but this is like straight up
like you know where they're just
happening it's common in my life yeah
I'm nude a lot yeah if you want to go
see it but April Fool's prank video you
know that's true like they the creator
of this might be someone who actually is
unable to dance now but was still able
to come up with some type of
choreography like they're using their
handicap way as an expression like
they're turning like these crushes and
stuff into like instruments they're
turning it into extensions and they're
turning it into like it's all symbolism
like these crutches is that first I
thought like oh these are just
handicapped folks but as it went on I
was like okay it seems like it's really
about something much more
art art is so abstract and there are
those two girls that did that
interesting number when they're hanging
from the harnesses oh yeah well they
didn't have crutches that they were
still being held up by harnesses
I feel like this thing is about feeling
like we're limited like these guys are
naked and exposed yet they have these
limits against them you're talking about
those two girls with the harnesses and
they're like kind of having like a dance
battle in a way but they're being held
back they're being held back from
fighting by the harness even with the
sexual stuff it's like I feel like in a
way this is a symbolism for not being
able to be your full self because we are
creating our own handicap in a way or
it's just flat-out weird and it doesn't
make any sense
and this choreographer just wanted to
confuse us that sounds more likely than
all the [ __ ] we came up with anyway
guys think she's telling me that the
weirdest video is out I mean there's a
lot of weirdest videos but makes tell me
this one was very weird it was weird if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where you
can hear more hypotheses on subjects
anymore but and Seymour butts
one day Lauren will show her but maybe
I'm Lauren Goss Channel oh you should go
check it out you should check out
Laurens Channel has a lot of fun stuff
on there variety yeah dating advice
vlogs like a lot of people requested
different dating advice videos I haven't
forgotten about that she want or not
asked or hot asian just look it up on
google and then maybe Lauren has funny
[ __ ] Google that I wonder what Google's
okay what's the top hit on how to pick
up Asian chicks anyway stay tuned for
that video yeah yeah that's what
continues to go to facebook.com slash
the real reject shoutouts where you can
earn yourself a shout-out by saying
something interesting he worked her
mm-hmm like an interesting
Stewart ooh keywords yeah something
interesting like something you liked
about the channel or in one of the
videos or us or some type of unique sex
maneuver that you'd want to do with
Lauren then maybe her boyfriend will be
down for yeah I don't read the shout-out
page so I guess you guys can write
whatever the [ __ ] you want about me yeah
she's into anal stuff I hear hardcore
anal stuff where is your what's your
source um the fact that you're Chinese I
don't know I don't imagine Chinese girls
are into that you know that shitty thing
about asian porn is they're always so
damn hairy
Asian but Asian girls are hairy yeah I'm
like in like straight like when they're
from asian porn like not Asian America
oh because they don't maybe maybe Asian
culture is it doesn't really emphasize
because I know American Asian girls tend
to like really clean up but my name
let's look an American thing in general
yeah yeah it's just like obviously
European women and have a different view
on it yeah I'm not a fan of the pubes
too much people care not a fan of a
little bit I'm okay with take care of